this is
Jocko underground podcast
number
60.
with Echo Charles and me Draco willink
we are sitting here
getting ready to record this thing and
I'm saying Echo Charles I'm saying
jockey what's in a name
I was thinking about this the other day
it turns out there's so there's a lot
there can be a lot in a name there's a
theory as I researched this there's a
theory or or should I say there's a i
hypothesis
that
people tend to gravitate toward things
in life
that kind of fit their names which is an
interesting thing to think about the the
hypothesis is called the nominative
determinism
name driven outcomes so whatever your
name is there's a decent chance that
that might influence the way you think
and where you end up in life maybe
decent chances a strong word and we'll
get some of the research here there's a
October issue of the psychologist
and it says that authors
authors gravitate towards areas of
research that fit their surname
this is this is this is research yeah uh
the example in the article they use
there's an article on incontinence from
uh the British Journal of Urology and
it's written by Dr AJ Splat and Dr D
weedon
you see what I'm saying it's kind of
strange right it seems strange yeah uh
there is another magazine a British
magazine had some good examples there's
a guy named Andrew drinkwater
who works at the water Research Center
there's a guy named Dr will welfare
who's works at the public health
department in England
there's a guy named Alan too good who's
a Samara involunteer
a woman named Dr pan Graves Pam Graves
and she's an archaeologist
there's a guy named Tom kitchen guess
what he is he's a chef yes you see what
I'm going a woman named Sarah blizzard
BBC weather weather reporter
guy named Aaron Farr he's a distance
Runner
uh when you speak of running
Usain Bolt
okay you see what I'm saying yeah
so there is a little bit of research
behind this and look
it looked like even the numbers that
they threw up were it's pretty minimal
it's not like this direct correlation
but at the same time from I started
thinking about this pragmatically like
how does this apply to us
as people in what we do and how we
interact and how we interact in groups
and how we lead groups if we're leading
groups
think about
when you give
a team a name
or when you give a nickname to someone
right so if you nickname your kid
dummy
you see what I'm saying how's that going
to work out yeah if you nickname your
kid champ hey champ come here how's that
going to work out look is this 100
correlation
no but let's face it if your nickname
your kid dummy or you nickname your kid
champ now look you can nickname your kid
champ and then think they should win
everything and now they are a brat right
could that happen sure but
if you nickname your kid knucklehead
or you nickname your kid Ace you see
what I'm saying these these can have and
they they did some legitimate in reading
some of these things they had some
legitimate things the way this turns out
uh and the real obvious examples
is like naming a team or naming a
military unit hackworth
in the Korean War he took over Fox
company and changed it immediately to
fighter company
think about what that does to the
mentality when he got to Vietnam he
would he took over the Hopeless
battalion
and he changed it to the
hardcore baton I think we might have the
hard Luck
hard luck baton oh confused but he
changed the name to hardcore why because
the other one doesn't even matter
anymore because we're the hardcore yeah
I did the same thing it's still team
three changed asking task in a Bruiser
so
this is an important thing to think
about it's an important thing here's
another thing like you're at work you
got a guy on your team what nickname do
you give them now in the SEAL Teams it's
awful you're going to get a nickname
that is making fun of you yeah
uh
that's the way it is I mean Dave Burke
you know Dave Burke's net call sign yeah
well now it's a good deal dude but the
call saying yes chip yeah chip which was
making fun of him because he chipped his
teeth on something yeah you know some
pilot thing sure all right so name
people and name things and nickname
people
positive things
and you are going to
at least have a chance that you have a
positive impact on the scenario yeah and
you know even you can nickname you can
name processes like you have a process
for something and if you name it you
know the drag
No One's Gonna like it yeah but if you
call it lightning
the people are gonna and you can see the
government when the government tries to
do this stuff too right they give things
they frame it a certain way
what do you think about your name Echo
yeah I don't know I just I I don't know
like what depends on what you mean so
you think it had an impact on your life
yeah compared to you have a twin brother
right your twin brother his name is also
kind of new unique right Jade yeah
did it have some kind of impact on you
yeah what kind of impact what if your
name was Bill yeah it fell in line with
the idea that I was just different a
little bit so I always felt different
and I don't know in what way to be
honest I don't even know what even that
even means but you know like I guess
most it that's kind of the irony right
where we all feel different
we all feel like we're different right a
little bit I mean I don't know maybe we
do maybe don't I know I did put it that
way so you felt different yeah because
your name
my name was one of the things that made
me what else even more even more
different I don't know like I guess when
you think about it what that I had a
twin brother that made me different do
you remember when you realized that you
were a person yeah what was it two years
old what do you remember doing this when
when people would ask me how old are you
you know it's a common question and I do
this and I remember seeing this like
between my fingers to your own fingers
yeah so between my two fingers making a
two and then it like Spiral you ever did
this where
maybe when you're a kid when you look at
your hand and you're like this is holy
cow oh yeah this is me oh this is me
like I'm up and you just spiral it's
almost like insanity a little bit you
know you ever get that oh I remember
yeah that started at two years old I
remember yeah I I'm gonna have to dig
back into my memory because I remember
thinking about this like like two years
ago I was thinking about I sort of
remembered
when I remember to being like Oh I'm a
person yeah and I have autonomy in the
world and I can do what I want to do and
there's going to be forces fighting
against me but I can get strong to where
I can defeat those forces yeah that
remember those thoughts no I've never
had before no I never had that thought
well here's what I here's what I think
uh so my my nickname Jocko is a nickname
right but it's a nickname I've had ever
since I was born so even before I was
born that was my nickname
what that what I think that did
influence is that when I would meet this
is back in the 70s man there was no
weird names everyone has a weird name
now right like legitimately every kid is
named like it's a weird name my kids all
have weird names like it's just a your
kids have weird names right
they're mediocre weird I guess it's not
John Bill and Mike and Jen so back in
the day when I was going into you know
first grade second grade kindergarten
you go out on the schoolyard whatever
you're meeting Bill you're meeting Frank
you're meeting David and then there's
this freaking kid whose name is Jocko
which is which is a totally different
type of name they don't know what it is
so I'm immediately like you're gonna get
made fun of kind of you're going to be
noticed a little bit and what you have
to do is you have to be able to at a
very young age
I had to be able to negotiate a little
bit of
awkwardness and maybe a little bit of
teasing or maybe a little bit I had to
learn to negotiate that at a young age
yeah and I think that made me
comfortable interacting with people at a
young age and thinking oh you know oh my
name is Jaco what kind of name is that
it's a dumb one you know but that's what
my parents get whatever like the little
things so I think that that like the
same as having the name Echo kind of you
have to
you have to learn how to negotiate
having a strange name that you actually
have to explain yeah
every time I probably had to explain my
name to every person I met for the first
10 years of my life
did they
that makes sense same here you know what
I'm saying still even what kind of name
is Jocko and again I think nowadays you
know you meet people named whatever
their name they got everyone's got a
weird name you go to the kids Jiu Jitsu
class it's a bunch of weird named kids
you know everyone's more unique now I
guess but legit back in the day you know
my my wife's name is Helen
her brother's name is John yeah my
sister's name is Jenny my sister's name
is Julie you know like my dad's name is
John it's just that's the way it is
everyone just had normal names and all
of a sudden boom here's this weird kid
named Jocko yeah you gotta I gotta
explain that I gotta be able to contend
with it people are gonna make fun of it
yeah did they did they ever make fun of
you like because Jocko's not a name just
like my name's not a name that they're
gonna be mean about it
what name would they be mean about
um
if your last name was I don't know there
was this oh like hamburger or something
yeah you could get some bad last names
yeah especially last names yeah there's
certain Filipino last names if you're
not Filipino they'll sound funny like
there's one um macadang dang
that was one that I remember very common
in Hawaii well no in the Philippines if
in Filipino yes and there's a lot of
Filipinos in Hawaii for sure so you had
you had a number of friends whose last
name was Michael Jackson Just well this
was elementary school so this was and
yeah you're right later on in high
school there's like yeah there's a bunch
of people named but the first girl that
came in she came from the Philippines
too so she had a thick Filipino accent
and her last name was Maka dang dang
when your kindergarten first grade
second grade that sounds funny so
they're gonna be teasing it like it it's
an actual funny last name Echo is like
oh is there an echo in here oh what's
your name Echo what is it Echo what is
it Echo you know like that kind of stuff
but that's not mean that's just like oh
they're trying to be funny or whatever
so yeah you contend with that Jocko
doesn't seem like one they'd be that
would be mean because it kind of sounds
cool yeah then generally speaking Yeah
it was more of like curiosity or maybe
make a little joke you know I used to
say people who couldn't name is that I'd
be I'd look at him with a straight face
when I was you know eight years old and
I go oh it's short for a job
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground